who you think really won who you think
really are the winners and losers from
you know the trades we got the Broncos
the 49ers the Ravens the Eagles the
Vikings and the Dolphins
well I think the Niners clearly I mean
they got a little bit of a head start
and and got to see they you know we we
got to see them three touchdowns three
different ways
um and Debo didn't even play so that's
that's huge uh I think Miami is eating
in a big way you know they got their
running back um and Jeff Wilson Jefe is
a really good back and and he's going
back to Mike McDaniel scheme Mike
McDaniels who's with him in San
Francisco
um so I think the Dolphins is really
doing some some work you know they doing
some work their record ain't the
greatest right now but they got all the
pieces tours playing crazy tariq's
playing Crazy Water's playing crazy
got another good running back and
defensively they were solid if their
Corners both come back that's a solid
Duo you know and Xavian
um and uh and and and Jones but in Byron
Jones but jdns you know we're we're up
and down but now they're not you know
what I mean Chubbs is about to come in
there and make a huge difference and I
think that Denver Broncos felt
comfortable with Browning already so
they were like that drive against the
Colts we had that game where Chubb went
out for like two series and Browning I
want to say yeah two sacks two sacks and
a tfl or something I kind of I kind of
saw the writing it on the wall then you
know when they see somebody else can do
it yeah in that fight slower it's
cheaper and they can do it yeah
I can't do it but so I think the Miami
Dolphins the San Francisco 49ers the
Baltimore Ravens getting a classic
Baltimore Ravens kind of player you know
what I mean a middle linebacker that can
sideline the sideline you know that's
Baltimore's always known for defense so
I think it's a win for them I think it's
win for Denver you know to get to get
them picks back that they lost trading
for Russ you know they didn't have a
first round and now they're getting the
first round they're back that helps that
team but
we'll see